ah
ó
vou começar uma história mostrando ali
no meio àquele sou eu
trabalhando numa colheita de abacates é
no final do ensino médio ensaio onde eu
fiz um intercâmbio de um ano e poucos
meses depois disso eu estava fazendo um
teste vocacional que tinha como objetivo
me ajudar a entender se um filho de pais
arquitetos com irmão estudante de
medicina estava fazendo a sua opção
baseado nas suas próprias aptidões ou se
era uma influência do irmão
então escolhi estudar medicina e depois
de seis meses nessa trajetória seis anos
nessa trajetória eu me vi novamente com
uma dúvida do que fazer para dar
continuidade à minha formação eu visitei
a idéia de fazer psiquiatria e cirurgia
e optei por estudar a cirurgia é passada
sair os dois primeiros anos de
residência novamente outra dúvida do que
fazer e escolhi a cirurgia plástica que
pra mim
a ideia era revestida de glamour e
charme de uma especialidade que têm a
ideia mística de promover o
rejuvenescimento de e promover a beleza
então tudo isso pra mim era muito
fascinante
eu não via a hora de começar a fazer
cirurgias estéticas e de colocar um
primeiro silicone
esse era o meu maior objetivo
fiz residência no hospital clássico de
belo horizonte com uma equipe de
profissionais bem sucedidos renomados e
isso fez aumentar ainda mais a minha
expectativa é qual foi a minha surpresa
ea minha é impressão já nos primeiros
contatos da cirurgia plástica de
participar de uma cirurgia de fenda
palatina é uma deformidade é comum em
nossa comunidade
agora pra mim é aquele tratamento era da
competente
o dentista e não do cirurgião plástico e
eram muitas as cirurgias de lábio
leporino e fissura de palato já que o
hospital era uma referência regional em
deformidades crânio-faciais e eu não
esperava não conseguia aguardar a hora
de fazer abdominoplastia mama plastia as
lipoaspirações e de colocar o bendito do
silicone e aí
um certo dia apareceu no ambulatório de
cirurgia plástica do hospital da baleia
para a primeira avaliação o chris
o cris portador de uma deformidade grave
que interessa o crânio ea face
características de uma síndrome muito
rara chamada síndrome das brigas
amnióticas ocorre uma alteração no
desenvolvimento do feto ainda durante o
primeiro mês de gestação ocorre essas
fissuras na fácil essas fissuras são da
família das fissuras lábio-palatinas é
conhecidas popularmente como lábio
leporino ou fenda de palato muito mais
freqüentes na nossa comunidade eo cris
começaria logo a fazer o tratamento
inicial o tratamento dele o tratamento
do paciente com fissura passou a fazer
cada vez mais parte da minha atividade
começou a ter uma importância maior na
minha vida
na abordagem das fissuras
o paciente é tratado da reconstrução do
lábio em torno dos três meses de idade é
feito uma cirurgia que dura em torno de
60 minutos ea cirurgia do palato é feito
a partir de um ano de idade e promove
condições para que a pessoa fale
normalmente sem ficar fanha nesses
procedimentos
os pacientes chegam para o tratamento na
maioria das vezes ainda bebês entrou no
centro cirúrgico com uma deformidade
grave que interessa a face que é uma
estrutura tão nobre pra gente
essa deformidade que constrange a
família os pais e amedronta os
familiares os vizinhos e saem do centro
cirúrgico reabilitados com a
possibilidade de sorrir normalmente eu
gosto muito de falar que o sorriso é a
manifestação dos lados enquanto os olhos
encontram o que o coração procura então
isso passou a fazer muito mais sentido
para mim essa ideia transformou a minha
carreira e essa ideia transformou a
minha vida é pouco depois disso é e eu
acabei a minha concluiu concluir a minha
formação de três anos e eu não tinha
mais dúvidas
eu queria continuar trabalhando com
deformidades faciais de crianças
eu continuei trabalhando no hospital
onde eu me formei eu continuei
trabalhando ensinando residentes
tentando despertar neles o mesmo
interesse que eu tinha por essa
atividade e aquele jovem indeciso lá do
início da história se transformou num
cirurgião plástico apaixonado pela
cirurgia reconstrutora então depois de
viver isso aí
alguns anos depois eu resolvi
incrementar a minha formação fazendo uma
especialização em são paulo a
especialização em cirurgia
craniomaxilofacial ali eu vivenciei
hospitais referência no tratamento
dessas atividades
tive contato com profissionais renomados
nacional e internacionalmente nessa
atividade e foi em são paulo também que
eu conheci uma cirurgiã que tinha uma
história muito parecida com a minha ela
também era ela era apaixonada pela
cirurgia o paciente fissurado é ela me
ensinou a assentar antes das cirurgias
com as fotografias do paciente e com os
livros e planejar minuciosamente aquilo
que a gente ia realizar na cirurgia e
ela me ensinou também a sentar depois da
cirurgia com a foto do antes e do depois
procurar as mínimas imperfeições e ela
está sempre falando assim enquanto a
aparência não está normal ainda não tá
bom eu brinco eu falo que ela parece ser
descendente direta de hipócrates o pai
da medicina porque ela consagra sua vida
em função da medicina
ela não descansa enquanto tem um
paciente sob seus cuidados e ela honra a
nobre tradição da profissão médica com
ela eu me inspiro nós tentamos fazer
esse tipo de medicina na sua forma mais
pura priorizando o tratamento do
paciente o seu bem estar pessoal físico
social e não foi à toa que eu me casei
com ela porque é ela me despertou coisas
é muito maiores e com ela eu comecei uma
outra bonita história que vai ficar para
um outro tex e essa é essa cirurgia que
me despertou é guiado também por esse
amor a esse trabalho nós nos tornamos
voluntários da operação sorriso que é
uma organização que promove missões
cirúrgicas para tratamento gratuito de
pacientes adultos e crianças carentes
portadores de malformações no mês
passado eu fui a porto velho em rondônia
onde operamos cerca de 60 pacientes ea
gente sabe que mudamos pra sempre a vida
desses pacientes porque a gente devolve
o sorriso a autoestima ea perspectiva de
inclusão social
essa atividade se contrata muito com que
nós vemos hoje em dia sobre a medicina
ea cirurgia plástica a gente observa uma
grande banalização da cirurgia plástica
podemos observar isso é com uma busca
incondicional pela beleza e pela
juventude
é nas séries de televisão
nas imagens as fotografias nas redes
sociais
existe uma supervalorização da estética
e uma busca sempre por transformar o que
é normal em excepcional enquanto
diferente disso no paciente com uma
deformidade
a gente tenta transformar o excepcional
em normal
então essa é uma grande diferença que a
gente percebe
eu não estou fazendo propaganda negativa
da cirurgia estética pelo contrário
considerando que a saúde é o bem estar
físico e psíquico e social entendemos e
trabalhamos com isso na nossa rotina
entendendo que podemos promover saúde
tratando alterações estéticas e isso pra
gente também é muito importante
é o christopher voltou ao ambulatório
para o início do tratamento o início do
planejamento da das cirurgias
eu expliquei para os familiares que essa
deformidade era muito complexa
eu falei que nós estudaremos o caso
planejaríamos a cirurgia e faremos o
melhor trabalho possível e para adequar
as expectativas
eu informei o pai do cristo afirma que
não ia ficar perfeito que a gente ia
melhorar a situação da criança ea
resposta do pai do que isto foi
emblemática pra mim eu confesso que foi
diferente do que eu esperava
o pai do christopher chegou pra gente
falou doutor
meu filho é perfeito e ele realmente
queria dizer isso o pai do cristo já
entendia ali que o filho estava em
condições perfeitas
esse é o cristo ou seja depois de duas
cirurgias e ele ainda será submetido a
outras e esse é o pai do cris que virou
uma referência pra gente e uma
inspiração para a continuidade do
tratamento
esse tipo de paciente a beleza como
perfeição das formas sempre imperou na
vida do homem mas a beleza vai muito
além da harmonia das formas muito além
da simetria a beleza é a paz ao nosso
redor
a beleza e serenidade do espírito
a beleza é a consciência interior
a beleza é muito mais verdadeira no
sorriso e na manifestação espontânea
ilegítima de amor
no meu entendimento e eu gostaria de
encerrar essa história
desejando que cada um de nós
independente do que faça possa encontrar
a melhor forma de se transformar e
transformar o mundo ao nosso redor
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]